Let's compare the difference between a token bucket
and a leaky bucket. The token bucket permits traffic
to be bursty, but it bounds it by the rate row. On the other hand, a leaky
bucket simply forces the bursty traffic to be
smoothed. The bound in a token bucket is as
follows. If our bucket size is beta, then we
know that in any interval T, then the rate
is always less than beta, that is, the
maximum number of tokens that can be accumulated
in the bucket, plus the rate at which
tokens accumulate, times that time interval. We also know
that the long term rate will always be
less than rho. Token buckets have no discard
or priority policies, whereas leaky buckets typically implement
priority policies for flows that exceed the smoothing rate.
Both are relatively easy to implement, but the token
bucket is a little bit more flexible since it
has some additional parameters that we can use to
configure burst size. One of the limitations of token
buckets is the fact that in any traffic interval
of length T, the flow can send beta plus
T times rho tokens of data. If a network
tries to police the flows by simply measuring their traffic
over intervals of length T, the flow can cheat by sending this amount of data in
each interval. Consider, for example, an interval of
twice this length. Well if the flow can send
beta plus T times rho in each interval, then over 2T the flow can consume 2
times beta plus tau times rho tokens. But
actually this is greater than how much the flow
is actually supposed to be able to send which is beta plus 2T times rho. So
policing traffic being sent by token buckets is
actually rather difficult. So, token buckets allow for long
bursts, and if the bursts are of high
priority traffic, they are difficult to police and
may interfere with other high priority traffic. So
there's some need to limit how long a token
bucket sender can monopolize the network.